I think on this beautiful afternoon in
New York we can begin I know that the
president would like to spend a little
more time outside the last account but
he does have to leave fairly promptly so
president buczek president buczek
ambassadors ladies and gentlemen there
could be no greater honor for anyone
associated with Europe at Columbia than
to welcome president buczek to us today
I'm David friedberger director of the
Italian academy but I speak on behalf of
president Bollinger and my colleagues in
all European institutions at Columbia
indeed the rest of the University who is
honored to have with us this afternoon
the president of the european parliament
indeed since today's event has been
co-sponsored by Columbia's Alliance
Program by the european institute and
the School of International and public
affairs in collaboration with the
European Union delegation to the United
Nations the European Legal Studies
Center and the European Students
Association the directors of all these
Institute's should really be joining me
in this task of offering an accolade to
President buczek but as director of
Columbia's Italian Academy your hosts in
this building this afternoon it falls to
me not only to extend my welcome to all
of you this afternoon but also to convey
my condolences to President buczek and
his compatriots with us this afternoon
on the tragic loss that Poland has so
recently suffered with the deaths of
president kaczynski and all those with
him on the plane to katene i'm going to
leave the real introduction to my
colleague John mitts co-director of the
east central european center executive
director of the european institute and
also he has many in karoke as we say in
Italian you forget when in these
European context which language you are
speaking and of course the more we can
keep English out of the lingua franca of
Europe probably these days the better I
won't risk my polish on you but John to
get back to the polls as many in karoke
whatever that might be many jobs I
suppose at Columbia and he can speak
much better about President buczek than
I but can I just say that those of us
who have lived in or being involved with
Europe in any way have known and admired
yes he Bulls act for many many years in
1980 he drawing solid are not and became
chair of the Public Works Committee so
I'm just going to briefly briefly
because John will give you the full
works about President buczek but he
drives Saladin osh in 1980 became chair
of the Public Works Committee we all
know that from nineteen or we didn't
know then but from 82 to 87 he published
that lively and illegal underground
pamphlet s very important in that
underground activity around solid are
not after the triumph of 1989 he
returned to his career as a professor of
chemical engineering you know I think
the time has come to expand our
fellowship program here at the academy
and to offer fellowships in chemical
engineering so when eventually you leave
from politics and go back to the ivory
tower which you have graced before you
are coming here he was prime minister of
poland from 1997 to 2001 and during his
term he had the amazingly important task
of taking poland into nato and
negotiating perhaps even more
complicated lee the terms of poland's
entry into the european union it's
hardly surprising that he should have
been elected president of the european
parliament in july last year with the
largest majority ever since the
inception of that parliament in 1969
1979 so please join me in welcoming
welcoming gary busey on behalf of
columbia this afternoon
so I now have the pleasure of
introducing my colleague John midscale
whom I've already spoken about to tell
you more and as briefly as he can about
President buczek because we want to hear
President buczek himself John thank you
you have the way I would have been
briefed anyway but now I really will be
brief you all know who our distinguished
visitor is today for those of you who
are perhaps under the age of 25 you
probably know professor buczek as the
father of Agatha buczek who is a very
well-known star who's making a career in
Poland and abroad and who recently
starred in an excellent film called
revis which will probably be
impenetrable to most Americans because
it's kind of Polish in a way and there's
too much to explain for me to say too
much about it but President buczek has a
lot of friends and right now most people
are cheering for another two years of
leadership inside the European
Parliament I don't think I have to say
much more on behalf of our guests that
David friedberg hasn't already said I
will say that it is not every day that
we receive somebody who has the
responsibilities that Professor buczek
has in Brussels if anybody has a lot of
work to do it is certainly he and when I
looked on the European Union site and
found that he had 14 vice presidents I
said to myself thank you I'll just be
happy with what I can do by myself so
let me please turn it over to president
music
thank you very much Thank You professor
Mike McGill professor friedberg for
presentation for kind words i will let
me start with one interesting thing
which happened to me just after election
european parliament some german
journalist came to me and asked if I may
be new or maybe I have any relations
with the Polish actress I gotta buczek
so so well I was very surprised because
they didn't know me but they knew my my
my daughter so it was great you can
imagine you can imagine what does it
mean for the poor father that daughter
is much more better known than that he
himself so it was great for me great
news once again professor Maggie
professor friedberg thank you also for
four words of sympathy to my country so
it's always very very important to think
that we are in community of people
Western democracies democracies and we
understand so well each other and we can
overcome difficulties just even thinking
about ourselves and it is being very
very helpful ah well I'm delighted to be
able to address you today because as a
professor myself I always feel at home
when I come to a university especially
such a university at Columbia like
Columbia I would like to say too much
about
because you are probably too proud of
that so I should not male made to add
anything for that mushy professor but
very well now and in my country
something special to be here to study
here and to have any contact with you in
university well let us say few words
about past because you mentioned
solidarity I grew up in a system where
art was censored where history was
falsified and world politics had only
one color this is why I choose the hard
sciences ah not only one reason because
I liked it all my life it was tremendous
just to do something which is concrete
politics is not as concrete as hard
sciences other than all the other hand
in politics you can influence much more
than in the case of hard sciences
usually what it was easier with hard
sciences in communist times because even
the Communists had to accept that one
plus one equals to at least be usually
the executive there were some some
expectations from them sometimes to
think in different way dear friends
going back to our times to our topic as
a matter of fact I would like to make a
few remarks about the political system
in the European Union following the
entry into force of the DS we
are going from Chitty to treat you must
know we are all the time in transition
period in the European Union is very
important to underline you stated your
United States 240 years ago something
like that more or less having the same
Constitution let so on so on so you
could get useful that it's quite
different European Union
enlargement nest next conscious stumped
starting for small group of countries so
we are in transition system now is
another next treaty very important and
what that treaty means for both Europe
and the United States going through
European Parliament because it's our
topic I would like to to mention it once
again just to remind all of us after
Lisbon as transient european parliament
in the transatlantic partnership well i
will i will keep my talk fairly short so
i prepared each in in written form
because it's easier for me to be shorter
not to have too many comments on the way
I I hope it will be the case and then
questions and comments and questions and
comments from from from yourself I would
be especially interested to hear you and
your own views on these issues let us
start for Europe from European
Parliament well to understand how
European Union works how we can put
forward our politics first let me say a
word about European Parliament which I
know have the honor to chair it's great
honor for me the parent has been on a
rising curve of power over the last
quarter century lisbon treaty takes that
power to a new level already in most of
the routine areas of lawmaking like
single market transport the environment
employment development policy and
intellectual property the parliament has
been caught with the council for
Meniere's what does it mean european
parliament is a lower chamber for our
legislative and council
guided by rotating presidency one
government after another Avenue every
government half a year having presidency
of the council it's a upper chamber two
chambers and for many years in those
areas I mentioned you a co-equal however
now with the Lisbon Treaty we move
further not even a step strong the
further we are co-equal with the council
it means upper chamber in low making on
agriculture and Fisheries international
trade policy justice home affairs and so
on so on nearly all international
agreements additionally including all
trade agreements now we need the
parliaments explicit approval we have a
right of veto we have already seen the
implications of that on final data
transfer as you know it is a named swift
of tftp Swift it means data transfer
connected with the probability of
terrorist attack is a banking data and
others so let me let me say European
Parliament is now very equal and similar
to your Congress to American Congress
being elected like American Congress
directly in the whole European Union
every member state every region of
European Union having the old
representatives in european parliament
in a fake in effect like in the united
states we now have we now have a lower
and upper chamber European Parliament
and the council in a single
big kamarul legislature EU political
system because if you want to know about
cooperation United States European Union
is very important to understand and to
know about political systems in the
European Union how we can contact what
is important just to observe our
relations in parallel things have
changed on the executive site the
meetings of heads of state and
government heads of state of the end
government 27 of them because we have 27
member states so-called European Council
not counsel at European Council become a
separate formal institution chair by
Herman Van Rompuy this body gives
overall guidance to the Union setting
the big long-term priorities for the
union today such a priorities Europe
2020 strategy 2020 what to do how to
organize themselves to be competitive
and so on so on so saying what is what
is comparable with European Council
European Council is something like
collective president of the United
States it's not the same actually but
more or less we can imagine because it
must be simple we have to legislate two
chambers is simple we have collective
president and of course we need
administration and we have we have
administration as you have Americans is
European Commission that's all so simple
now you understand everything
simply stated once again the council is
now the counterpart of the European
Parliament as Europe's legislative and
budgetary authority there are two
chambers the Commission is
administration and the group in Council
collective president jointly form the
executive in this system the Member
States still remained very important
while it's big difference you have
states but you're 50 states didn't don't
have such a responsibility much well you
you went from from different position at
the end of 18th century and now we are
in the European Union not strongly
United but start starting from quite
independent member states so still they
are very important but the European
level is a supra supriya national level
has been strengthened and the exercise
of power is shaped more than ever by the
community method something new in
richmond city boy well very standard now
qualified majority voting not an anime
anime animated he said the norm in the
council it means in the upper chamber
now co-decision between the council and
parliament is the norm the
intergovernmental message between
governments in drooping council mainly
between Prime Minister's Chancellor's
still has its place but in a smaller
sphere in decision-making or foreign and
security policy financial resources of
the Union and some aspects of monetary
union so you see everything shifted
towards community it makes our union
stronger more United 500 million people
biggest economy all over the world and
biggest try it
all over the world foreign policy is
very interesting because we have also
put in place new arrangements in the
field of foreign policy which is very
important everything's global today you
know very well terrorism is global
crisis is global climate issues global
we have a new High Representative also
vice president of the european
commission baroness cassation she chairs
the foreign affairs council council is a
member of the european council and also
is connected with european commission so
it's only one such a person in the whole
european union because it was a question
of office you know Kissinger question
about one telephone number to the
European Union is one person in European
Union is a member of European Council it
means collective president she's a
member that's collective she is a member
of European Commission so member very
strong of administration of the European
Union and she's a member of the council
it means upper chamber of the European
Union one person and three
responsibilities also power very big the
external departments of departments of
the Commission and council will be
merged into a new European external
action service this will give the you a
more coherent structure for developing
and implementing foreign policy and
present a more united face for partners
and allies around the world let us go to
transatlantic transatlantic perspectives
dear friends so we have a new design to
the political system on the European
side lisbon treaty should help natural
coordinate us Europeans our policies
both internally and externally
to develop better dealing with the rest
of the world so important for our
citizens if we won't respond their
expectations critical critical to our
success is the transatlantic partnership
I'm feeling very strong we need each
other more than ever before neither of
us is big enough in today's global world
to achieve our goals on our own you are
after difficult decades we'll remember
in the European Union 11 of September
heart decades crisis everywhere and on
the other hand Europe is reunited once
again and stronger so we can be equal
partner for us in this second decade of
the 21st century the relative power of
both of us Europe and United States is
already decreasing by the year 2000 2500
CD countries are expected to produce
only forty percent of the world's output
compared to well over half at the moment
almost sixty percent so we having sixty
percent of GDP today all over the world
gdp in 15 years forty percent only and
Asia will jump from 30 to saturate
the same is the demography the rise of
China India and other new players makes
this clear to Europe in the United
States over the last decade you have
probably discovered the limits of
American power how are we to respond the
crucial question both communities on the
both sides of the Atlantic sea together
I believe that we need to take the lead
in building and shaping a new form of
global governance I have always liked my
friend Bob Zoellick from World Bank a
former congressman has put it that we
need to modernize multilateralism the
hard truth is that unless the West is
united we will lose the ability to
defend and advance our interests and
values which is as important for us as
interests if we are united we can help
define international responses in the GH
WTO or g20 we put on the table together
any proposal it is valid for everybody
of course we will not be able to solve
all major international challenges on
our own two entities not enough today
transatlantic community is not enough we
will need to cooperate and should want
to cooperate with a range of new
partners around the world but our
interdependence both of us Americans and
Europeans can and should make us
stronger in such a world America and
Europe should still serve an axis of
global stability and enlightened values
I repeat enlighted values
on which our democracy our civilization
was built is built we all know that the
difficult challenges we face today
economic insecurity energy independence
I mentioned few of them climates
immigration money laundering piracy
terrorism common action on these phones
is essential and in addressing these
issues we will need to find ways of
bringing on the board in different ways
Russia China India Brazil but for
climate issue Brazil cautious necessary
and so on so on even Saudi Arabia for
piracy South Africa they have to become
stakeholders in the new world order or
disorder so that so that they can expect
to have a genuine sense of ownership in
the way policy set because genuine sense
of ownership means possibility of
agreements on an issue with climate
issue you know how difficult it is
everybody feel should feel responsible
the time to do this is now wise Europe
and America are still powerful enough to
make a difference if we fail the 21st
century will be a century of insecurity
and instability of all of us we can see
it uncertain unpredictable difficult
word around more than 15 years ago 20
years ago it was so here Iron Curtain
while enemy it make you the West United
was not so easy on on eastern part of
Alton Karen carton but jam while on the
western part of Iron Curtain probably
you you could feel very very United
they come on enemies always easier to
keep us more disciplined dear colleagues
our transatlantic relationship is
already very strong already very strong
we know very why we feel fantastic all
the members European Parliament for all
our delegation my colleagues together
with me fantastic like being in Europe
everybody speaks English is much easier
while in Europe you know from country to
country you cannot go to sharpen to ask
about fantastic well but still yeah we
have the biggest change and investment
flows into watch we share the same
values and very many of our interests it
was the same of course we defer we have
a specific areas of legislation and
regulation which are in front of us
because we we don't understand each
other for example or we are not close to
each other you will know the cases be
paying vs. Airbus glory chlorinated
chicken very important issues sometimes
important and non-proliferation the rich
directive and recently Swift we can
address those in the transatlantic
Economic Council it is something like
that transatlantic Economic Council but
they think we should think bigger than
that we need to set ourselves and more
ambitious challenge for the 21st century
in 10 years time let us implement a
genuine transatlantic single market
based on the four freedoms which already
exist in Europe we have it freedom of
flow movement goods services capital and
people yes people i will add a fifth
freedom our research results together
with intellectual property rights which
is necessary to to improve but flow in
your search because education is
absolutely flow and is open but not not
yet research
transatlantic market could build on one
of the European Union's greatest success
stories we have great success story the
single market that we have building
continuously for over 50 years the day
before yesterday I addressed United
States Chamber of Commerce and
challenged the business community to put
forward the ideas and proposals to
achieve such a free market to look at
both sides of the Atlantic as one space
of 800 million citizens do they
challenge you young generation first of
all but all of you sitting here to think
of a euro-atlantic community not only
single market this should not be now we
should have what 25 30 40 years ago we
had desires and we were thinking about
being free countries it was impossible
even to think about that but we still
had such a desire so we could win having
in mind that is possible now we also
should think about euro-atlantic
community a common space where you can
leave work and study on either side of
this inner see which is the atlantic
ocean that may seen a dream but our
challenge is to change the context and
create a new reality let me say at the
very end next weekend 9th of May it
would be Sunday as far as i remember we
will celebrate 60th anniversary of the
famous declaration in paris by robert
schumann that leads to the European Coal
and Steel Community we must imagine 60
years ago germinate who wrote the
Declaration once said that everybody is
ambitious the question is whether he is
ambitious to be
or ambitious ambitious to do that does
be ambitious to do the pooling of
sovereignty in Europe of a call and
still pouring sovereignty on that which
at the time was the core of a nation's
industry was it an incredibly bold and
ambitious project sixty years ago the
six countries that took spar that took
part change Europe's face and Europe's
future not only that also our attitude
and approach to the international
relations we know that they can be
peaceful and we can go on the way of the
reconciliation between nations if it is
necessary today let us also be ambitious
to do let us dream not just of a strong
transatlantic partnership is not enough
let us create a genuine transatlantic
community European Parliament is ready
to cooperate and ready to support it any
time you wish thank you very much
Thank You President buczek following up
on something that David said very early
on in his introductory remarks it's
worth repeating that Columbia treasures
the relationship that it has with the
european union with the delegation at
the United Nations without whom this
meeting would not have taken place
without the cooperation of the aliens
program here at Columbia which brings so
many interesting speakers to Colombia
and which also has a network of partners
not just in France but but elsewhere
with the European student association
whose representatives are here in the
room and whom we also thank for their
cooperation and last but not least the
European Legal Studies Center here at
Columbia which the very name tells you
has a vested interest in pursuing
various sorts of research and
scholarship based on EU law we have
about a half an hour of time for
questions to president music and I would
only ask that when you ask your question
it is a question and not a statement
that it's short and that you please
introduce yourself before you you ask
your question sir
european parliament currently
controversial to congress suspended 25
that why understand the EU and 1.25
percent of GDP Europe so when it comes
to future info
the big difference between us but my
question would be this issue definitely
be cited by the gutter chamber or should
they if you like respond or you can okay
well maybe I will change reservation
would be easier for me just do does to
discuss what I said of course very
precise question it's a big difference I
agree with you because for for European
Parliament and European institutions is
not so also so much money it is our
weakness as a community as well because
we have our community budget while much
smaller in proportion that it is in
United States but what I hope decade
after decade will be better and better
from this point of view because it is a
very important is a strength but I hope
it is not everything money and budget at
least from point of view of European
Union if we want to build community in
which we change them war between
countries to negotiation it was the most
important idea of drooping union is
still valid you had Americans also some
trouble with Europa the first half of
the 20th century even later two world
wars started in Europe and we had to to
change from from worrying to be part of
a big family with great discussions that
is also important from point of view of
European Parliament's and we need such a
discussion in the European Union because
sir we
like to have diversity in languages you
have one language we have 23 23
languages well I i know that in some
parts could be possible also second or
third language in the united states year
by year but it's far away from that 23
languages is still existing in the rope
in Union and we want to to support it
it's our strength you need to in
diversity and European Parliament is
working very hard for lives to
understand each other we will leave
european parliament members 736 of us
end of thursday while morning friday
morning disappearing to other regions
spending three days in our regions and
then monday we are back we can discuss
we can express ourselves you could know
others what is going on in my region
what is happening what is good what is
not good fantastic so it's not only
budget which is important from the
position of european union you started
from different quite different
perspective having united one country
from the let's say very beginning so we
agreement with you but but i must add
such important issue as saying about
agriculture poles it is point of our
competitiveness in agriculture and and
food supply and is there are some points
which are important from this point of
view and k i can add that we certainly
will reform our agriculture policy but
we will not resign from the common
agricultural policy but we would like to
in introduce quite a new policy I I call
it a European energy community I propose
also something like that to be more
efficient in energy issue it's not
United with agriculture but reforming
agriculture policy it is also necessary
to intern
use new policies policies which could
make us more United and more efficient
endless border generally speaking except
of Europe I would say but it's not so
easy because it's necessary to fulfill
Copenhagen criteria democracy and some
other points very important human
women's rights for example for Turkey
some of them could be difficult about
the army for something about politics
well it's not easy also for Western
Perkins if if you would like to fulfill
it you must be really democratic
countries that's a great big triumph
trove of a European Union you know very
well end of 20th century 99 Kosovo hot
region Western Balkans you do not have
any problem you Americans we European
with Western Balkans why because they
are queuing to the EU membership is no
possibility to to fight each other must
be democracy as quick as possible
working free market economy as quick as
possible and we solve the problem that's
the power of the European Union and
influence we would like to keep our door
open but it takes time and I cannot tell
you if it will be in 10 years 20 years
certainly crusher or maybe 12 other
Western Balkan countries can join you in
next few years together with Iceland but
the further steps it is very difficult
to say
game mobile comm channel Choctaw when
you apply beautiful really
very cool step in 2004 in larger and etc
of patience for the creatures that loud
loud 44 by mistake special column three
very short questions
long album without its junk you the
credit bureau in 1985 we already said we
need a much smaller Parliament because
we all know the old criticism concerning
your viewing was lack of democracy there
is we have all common is our country sir
you can head over a parliamentary which
one are you writing point of mr.
president department has become much
stronger through this treaty which are
you precise the projects f-friends then
where are your priorities to use the new
strength of you can't i'm stationed
along there's no rule concerning
document that here i have to up little
more my home information is also embed
the militarization I organized the
beginning we think their informal
forming listen to our presidency 2006
and I believe you at it first country to
NY that the West bottom States all them
to take part in the unit
the formulas level you said that time
lines not very clear yet but again a
question which would be the next precise
spectacle certainly all need the form of
a project I mean we all know ERT
kommentare its 100,000 or more pages and
it's the third yourself chapters to
fulfill very difficult so we go the next
day and what again to the farm in doing
this context and very last question what
is your concern with a transatlantic
relations which are very important
little thing that we know people united
/ other producer for instance sitting
area what can power minus creature two
three four thank you very much strong
Parliament how how can i use a symmetric
the lisbon treaty is a treaty about
parliaments the european parliament is
much stronger as i told you except of
budget like like american congress I
know is very important maybe the most
important issue button but in Europe is
slightly different proportions we must
know about that and strong Parliament
very impressive democratic institution
on the one between all the European
institutions directly elected and first
point I would like to use it
transatlantic partnership so i came to
united states four years ago just with
clear message we are ready for strong
partnership and said to have a
connections with with a congressman with
this American Congress I had a long
discussion with Nancy Pelosi your your
speaker first of all beginning of
September in in Rome it was g8 meeting
just now with many congressmen more than
10 very influential congressman Congress
person sorry not sorry sorry Congress
Congresspersons very important while we
are taking care of that in the opinion
you cannot get through European Union if
you are not taking care about that so
well so it's a very important European
energy community I would like to support
it and European Parliament is supporting
me taking care bout next budget how to
organize it is another point the
Parliament is much stronger I can
influence European external action
service I was talking about because you
are as possible 4444 financial financial
regulations for staff regulations and
many things for while the budget so it's
a great power in the hands of of
Parliament and Human Rights which is
very important for all the members and
we are very active in this field so I'm
going very quickly to the next question
you asked about next step in enlargement
as I understood what of course casa it
was blockaded from from Slovenia because
of problems with with borders is the
same with turkey is a blockage from
Cyprus to do turkey membership today and
terms now is the possibility because we
arranged a quite a new situation in in
visa agreement so is a non visa regime
with some other countries Western
barker's only 3 or 2 J without this
possibility bosnia-herzegovina albania
and montenegro as far as i know others
in serbia former yugoslav republic of
macedonia very precise not doing any
mistake not everybody understands what
I'm thinking about but some of you yes
thank you for much thank you very much
and so it is great progress and I snug
of course Iceland disturbs us from time
to time in our inner allayed between
but we can manage we can forgive them
and you must you must remember they are
absolutely precisely between you a
between Europe and America you know very
well just in the middle the small leg we
called Atlantic Ocean don't know why so
so proud name and you see they are
divided western part should be America
and eastern parts will be geographically
as a matter of fact Europe but they want
to remember of European Union it's also
ours our child you see if you are
American you must be jealous about that
because it's tremendous island beautiful
if you have visited discuses is either
you know about that value is
well-organized i think is it will be
great well that's it probably what they
could ask because transatlantic
relations well I answered European
Parliament would like to do that lady
not only permanent of course Commission
and council as well but but Parliament
just would like to even take initiative
yeah back
oh yeah
yeah you know it was what question maybe
it was not not quite clear for everybody
who is sitting in the back of our room
which question about relations with
Russia after this horrible catastrophe
of of the Polish presidential plane well
it's complicated how does it look like
in the eastern part of our continent you
know very well French German
reconciliation in fifties sixties gave a
beginning of European Union and
integration on the West German Polish
reconciliation and of Ages nighters
started much aerial but ends of the
reconciliation gave unity for the whole
European Union for both both sides
central eastern and western Europe now
we need next step as all as usual very
difficult on eastern part not only
between Poland and Russia also between
other sensor Eastern European countries
and Russia because reconciliation is
necessary between closest neighbors
there's no point to go to reconciliation
between let's say poland and spain we
didn't have come the border and we don't
have nothing against each other so it's
not reconciliation we love each other
that's all reconciliation means
neighbors and it was French German
German Polish now in some countries in
eastern part of Europe they wait the
same with Russia and we are ready for
that central eastern european countries
and this horrible catastrophe could give
some impetus
to this process because we were deeply
touched by the Russian reaction full of
understanding and very warm full of
dignity on the catastrophe it's a book
big is a big difference in comprising
what was some years ago and also
thinking about the real the real problem
which is what happened seven years ago
in cutting delegation was just going to
cutting and the crash was before of
because of 70 70 years anniversary of
the massacre of Polish officers and
intellect what is 70 years ago bye bye
bye bye bye Soviet empire and if we go
on this way to enlight everything what
happened seven years ago it could be
good beginning for reconciliation not
only between polish for people and
Russian but also between others it may
be good beginning but we you never know
because as matter of fact Russia is not
democratic countries always more
difficult as you know France and Germany
over democratic country conscious also
at the end Germany and Poland but I am
optimistic openness is rather big
thanks
you mentioned the European
back and what that freshman the charger
one step 3 did you see they are like
good wrong they last won last the
European like this always
it is great to hear about 90 however
over the game
this issue
today
yeah sometimes we are sometimes united
states are are quicker sometimes
European Union is quicker in Georgia we
were quicker quicker than the United
States so you know it depends on on the
all the country but talking about
Constitution about Constitution it's too
early for the European Union to have
Constitution it's not easy because they
are different member states different
nations different languages so it could
be some problems with common
Constitution and if we solve this
problem in the future I would like to
guess today I think on the basis of
lisbon treaty we can be united in up and
strong enough and to have a common for
another foreign policy which is the most
important who have common foreign policy
and to answer the citizens expectations
outside european union because as I told
you everything is global and we must
tackle the problems outside European
Union if we want to help our citizens
crisis climate and so on so on energy
problem everything is outside opinion so
having common a foreign policy security
policy would be great step forward and I
know that one country which is
absolutely for many even longer than the
United States doing very well I think
without any Constitution you know the
country you're not a kingdom so you see
we can manage like unity King being even
maybe in future Empire you see
ok
like we are not a very quick comment
before my question now you said your
gravity Columbia is very far north yeah
yeah that is about 40 minutes of
questions if you are at the south end in
Manhattan roasting every single question
would have been to that grease now one
question under a fitted reference so my
question is not about greece but i just
wanted to point out as the difference
between the academic orientation is
about your project for a transatlantic
community and you met the united states
at this point is actually quite divided
on some political european idealism is
actually quite united in certain way and
as you mentioned when the Europeans
start coding school community
you have to start somewhere and that was
coated steel if you want to start the
transatlantic community
well which with five freedoms if we
start with five reasons we would wait we
don't have come single market between us
maybe for capital almost now we don't
know exactly with hedge funds but rest
maybe it's okay but rest flow flow of
people for example visa regime for four
countries european union members and all
other world goods for example removal
the goods we need common standards
without come on standard you cannot have
a free movement of goods and so on so on
services were far away from common
market if you have single common market
will be great for our community well
because we are very pragmatic as you
said we are very romantic so you need
much more romanticism and we need much
more pragmatic that would be great you
see let us go to us yeah some romantis
miss necessary
I am
is a question well can you give you
connect view a square in the written
form later because I must think about
that i didn't i didn't think way I
didn't have time to well I have another
200 half years in European Parliament
because he said my channel enough is
only 200 five years first part of the
term of European Parliament than 200
half years being ordinary member of
European Parliament I just last term
five years I was ordinary member of
you've implemented having such an amount
of work i was a member of Energy
Committee environmental committee and
Climate Change Committee you can imagine
well everything was so interesting and
going a higher than Zander and so on so
on so I gave it to a and a half years
time for thinking about that but
thankfully for your question I just
still start to it today certainly
Sheamus well it's a good idea great idea
many other countries not only Poland
would like to join who euro now they
want to influence on the eurozone by
stating together what it should be
working in the future until the end of
this year mr. Van Rompuy president while
president of our collective president I
would say president of our collective
president would like to finish response
for this issue until the end of the year
until December and to prepare
regulations supervision of the eurozone
in the proper way how it should work in
the future so for for all the countries
which want to join your opinion is open
and we want to join it's not easier now
because we are in crisis still were just
recovery step by step but certainly
eurozone will be richer for full next
five or six countries which are queuing
for your awesome
yes it's European Commission it means
administration it was saying in American
Way is Ahmet administration of the
European Union it means European
Commission who is mr. Barroso as a
leader of ribbon commission and they are
responsible for checking such as other
things and it's some delays I agree with
you some delays and so we should improve
it were also not quite clear everything
in eurozone so it's just some problems
and we would like to improve it very
very strongly and to check it every year
every half a year which is necessary
certainly certainly madam
year
sorry about butters yeah
and
maybe all the questions of neurology to
end and then all of them to answer
because it was going yeah yeah maybe
maybe to two or three other questions
very quickly madam yeah sorry
yeah yeah good question next question if
I could ask you what you sort of sorry
because you usually get not me but I am
so quick said well because my my my my
plane is is waiting and so Iceland is
not disturbing
proceed
briefly well next Nexus 3 only 31
three questions together madam okay you
are very very clever great well what
next big question yet please yeah yeah
yeah yeah
because
the last question madam
greece question
I asked for the last question because I
remember it and the rest you were
situation till the next meeting Wow haha
well okay crisis let us let us say very
very simple solidarity works in the
European Union and quite sure but except
solidarity we also need responsibility
and it was also questioned about how
European Commission is ready to check it
what is necessary with your union from
point of view of legal judgment and
that's it responsibility is necessary
also in economy if you have solidarity
with your support but I can tell you a
match mr. Papandreou Prime Minister six
weeks ago they prepared very tough hard
program of reforms is very difficult but
now now responsibility responsibility I
hope will work also in the case of
grades so solidarity works and in few
days it will buy my open will be
arranged madam Ashton the European
Parliament well we have a lot of
connections because we have almost 40
permanent delegations from European
Parliament to all the countries all over
the world one of the biggest and most
influential delegation constant
delegation is to United States we have
all soaped transatlantic logiciel
legislators dialogue we would like to
exchange staffers we would like to have
connect context on the level of
committees reporters to have joined
trips to third countries like India
Bangladesh or some others from european
parliament from american congress and so
on so on so between such activities also
so so important this European Parliament
activity and for madam Ashton
be great help if you are dealing with
Middle East today we have we have
euro-mediterranean Parliamentary
Assembly only one such a assembly all
over the world in which Palestinian and
Israeli sitting in the same hole using
the same microphone and talking with
other discussing fantastic so it's great
help for madam Ashton we are in constant
contact but a mess don't is a member of
three institutions so she is not member
only European Parliament because we were
voted on her and accepted her so we are
the constituency for madam Ashton we
European Parliament and she will come to
Europe in Parliament and to give report
what is going on and we are ready to
help her in her activity also in
transatlantic relations development and
climate women everything you asked
Madame very clever way while women of
course it is absolutely necessary we are
much better in Europe than you are in
American Congress because you have
eleven or twelve percent of women we
have more than twenty-five percent over
as far as I remember so it's necessary
absolutely we must unlock the potential
of women in our society we wouldn't like
to lose because it's absolutely
necessary is also connected with
research and with innovation with being
active in any fields and so on so on and
climate is finished well development and
climate are connected we must remember
about that no in development age without
thinking about climate because the
developing countries are in Africa they
are dying because not having water in
another places they are dying because
have floods like in Bangladesh or while
sea level eight thousand eight thousand
islands in Pacific so you see
development and climate is connected
while energy independence well if we
start if we start with shells we will be
from gas point of view independent we
have a lot of for shivers of course but
is a slightly difficult because of
climate issue Belarus is very important
issue we are very active in Belarus but
it is not only point of democracy I
would like to underline very strongly
it's all also point of independence of
Belarus they are dependent economically
very strongly on Russia today so if we
think about democratic Belarus we must
parallel we think about independence in
Belarus even for opposition which is
very strong as a matter of fact even
civil society Lukashenko is a hard
regime but the position is also stronger
stronger I can assure you we have a
visit of independent candidate for for
presidential election for years ago in
European Parliament who's awarded price
sakharov prize in European Parliament's
for peace for human rights and he is
always answering the question both are
important because it is impossible to
build democracy in future if it will be
the case that Belarus will will lose
independence so it's complicated I would
like to ask for you but it takes time to
to to to to say to see the problem from
many points of view everything takes
time I am very glad I had a possibility
to address